brace yourself my sweet summer theorists
tinfoil is coming I am terrible at
accents
hello Internet welcome to film theory
remember a Lannister always pays his
debts but for everyone else there's
MasterCard all right so if you haven't
figured it out yet I love Game of
Thrones I'm a Dany fan and Arya file and
most definitely on Team Tyrion I mean
seriously this channel is less than 10
episodes and we're already doing a
second video on it but believe me
there's good reason blog placement
seriously TV Club embed this video in
time for the season 5 finale
ok so shamelessly feeding the
entertainment media's content churn
aside I really do eagerly wait every
week for new episodes of this series the
world of Ice and Fire has some of the
deepest lore of any modern fantasy
universe and the best thing about it is
that it's still unfolding unlike some
other major fantasy standbys like the
Lord of the Rings and Harry Potter we
actually get to see the whole game of
Thrones saga on screen before the series
is actually finished
on that note though ger Martin if you're
listening to me really start to wrap
this series up because I'm not okay with
cliffhangers here seriously my friend
none of us are getting any younger
especially you in any case one thing I
love so much about good old gods is that
the back history of its universe
actually starts thousands of years
before any of the books begin we've just
now started to see some of the old
legends of Westeros become a reality and
that leaves tons of theorizing about
everything that's still coming one of
the topics I'm most excited about though
is a very specific prophecy that has
some serious implications and how the
entire course of this series is gonna
play out and before I get too much
deeper into that let me just say right
here there are some spoilers ahead we'll
be covering one prophecy that's brought
up in the book that's yet to be covered
in the TV show everything else will be
evidence drawing from the TV show itself
so if you're okay hearing about a
prophecy that may come into play down
line and are caught up with the episodes
rate you should be fine but don't you go
telling me that I didn't warn you about
spoilers and if my theories right well
then more spoilers but you know it's
just the theory wait save that for the
end so one of the most interesting
concepts introduced to viewers on Game
of Thrones is the mythical religion
centered around role or war role on
roller these things are just so
needlessly difficult the mythical
religion centered around the Lord of
Light in the heart of fire as you might
be able to tell by his unimaginative
titles he's a god of light and fire it's
pretty self-explanatory actually he's
the one all the red priests are super
excited about when they're burning
people at the stake and doing kinky
stuff with leeches these guys are doing
everything from seeing visions and
flames to bringing people back from the
dead and other weird stuff like birthing
shadow baby assassins I don't know I
mean yeah some of it is pretty extreme
but in terms of proving your God's
existence these powers seem awfully
legitimate the case is even better when
you compare them with the other Westeros
religions like the faith of the seven
which spurious Lee we haven't seen
anything out of these guys and they're
supposed to be seven of them good
teamwork they're friends and then you
have the old gods who don't seem to do
all that much except for grow some nifty
trees so where's the theory well in the
religion of the Lord of Light the God
rule or is the sworn enemy of another
God known as the great other much easier
to pronounce they're designed to be
equal and opposite forces in the world
it starts to get more relevant when we
find out that this great other is the
entity supposedly controlling the White
Walkers those ice zombies with the
sparkling baby blue eyes that come from
beyond the wall according to official
Game of Thrones lore years before the
events of the book series one of rulers
heroes rose up and defeated the White
Walkers against the great other for all
the years in between that event and the
events in the series these two didn't do
all that much but now that we hear that
winter is coming winter is coming winter
is coming winter is coming winter is
coming winter is coming winter is coming
winter is coming winter is yes okay we
get it
it's coming it's coming we get it thank
you now that winter is coming it seems
the White Walkers are back we
means that the great other is back with
them so with the white Walker invasion
becoming more and more of a threat one
activity everyone should really be doing
instead of making out with their
siblings and flaying people is reading
up on their own history if they did they
would find out plenty about how the hero
of rule or defeated the White Walkers
last time or maybe they could watch this
video instead that's also a possibility
the Walker Slayer no not that Walker
Slayer this Walker Slayer was as aura
high and lived roughly 8,000 years
before the events of the main series
during everyone's favorite the long
nights the stories the characters tell
about it vary slightly but it's just is
that during the long night the entire
world was dark
everyone starved and the White Walkers
attacked Westeros Ozora High was chosen
by rule or to defeat the White Walkers
but to do that he needed a weapon that
would actually kill them as we've seen
in the show using traditional weapons
against these things just get him
shattered into a cool spray of CGI so
what did is aura high do his first
attempt at forging a sword to take down
the White Walkers involved him working
the sword for 30 days and nights but
when he dipped the blade into water to
temper it it's shattered alright so take
to his second time out he worked the
metal for 50 days and nights then
captured a lion and plunged it into his
chest to temper it in the Lions blood
shattered again on his third and final
attempt he worked it for 100 days and
nights and sadly pierced his own wife's
heart to temper the blade this time it
worked
thank goodness because otherwise that
would have just been a really awful
waste of time and wife actually if you
think about it it's still pretty awful
anyway moving on the point was the steel
combined with the soul of his wife to
become the sword Lightbringer a weapon
that would make anything coming in
contact with the blade burst into flames
according to legend to Zora high use the
blade to beat back the White Walkers and
put an end to the Dark Knight full of
terrors that we hear lady Melisandre
talk about incessantly
jeez you know when you think about it
this show is really good at hammering
home its catchphrases into your head
winter is coming the night is dark and
full of terrors all men must die
Lannister always pays his debts
the larvae coulis whatever the Bravo's
people say point is the shows good at
branding and like all the best heroes
and fantasy novels there exists a
prophecy that one day after an
especially long summer the long night
would come again White Walkers with it
the new hero whose job it would be to
take down those White Walkers would be
recognized by a specific set of
characteristics he would have the blood
of a dragon would be born quote amidst
smoke and salt as a bleeding star shines
in the sky end quote and after his birth
dragons would follow shortly and thanks
to these characteristics people would
know that the prince that was promised
had come pretty exciting stuff so the
goal of today is to identify who is the
prince that was promised and we have a
few candidates when we first meet her in
the series lady Melisandre believes our
Savior will be good old Stannis all Sulc
and no play Baratheon and he buys into
the prophecy himself setting up weird
rituals to try and fulfill the
requirements but does he technically has
the blood of the dragon from some
distant Targaryen ancestor but I'm not
really sure about that smoking salt
thing he burns people alive and was
reborn through the religion maybe then
there's the question of the bleeding
star unlike certain other characters
we'll talk about he has no connection
with the bleeding star that we saw in
the sky throughout season one so Stannis
yeah it's a bit of a stretch I don't see
this one holding water however we do
have other options with the most obvious
being Daenerys Targaryen in a story
that's packed with protagonists
antagonists and anti-heroes she's
probably the closest thing to a main
character we're gonna get her Ark
follows a fairly archetypical hero
journey where she starts with basically
nothing then finds a cause worth
fighting for and believing in freeing
all slaves she grows then she learns
suffers hardships and betrayals and
eventually becomes a great leader so it
would seem like that puts her into a
prime position but more importantly she
fulfills the prophecy
let's look at our checklist danny is
definitely a Targaryen so she has a
direct tap on the blood of the dragon
that's easy and though we don't know
much about her birth in the series we
see her rebirth after the death of
everyone's favorite set of pectorals
Khal Drogo Danny walks into her former
husband's funeral pyre the next day
she's still alive with dragons in tow
naked as the day she was born it's
symbolic that she's been reborn she's no
longer a follower a mother or a wife to
a great leader she is the great leader
the Queen the one who will rule over the
Seven Kingdoms so you see not all nudity
in the series is senseless just most of
it and that scene checks two important
qualifications off our list borne and
smoke and with Dragons shortly following
then to top it all off during the ritual
where she became the mother of dragons a
red messenger otherwise known as a
comment appeared over esos and Westeros
the symbol that passes pretty nicely for
a bleeding star so then what about being
born of salt well one of the biggest and
earliest tests of her role as a leader
was getting the Dothraki across the
Narrow Sea
seas consist of salt water born of smoke
and salt
the only real qualification here she's
missing is the whole prince thing but
hey George RR is a progressive dude so
maybe gender stereotypes don't apply
here on the other hand she's not the
only near-perfect match there's another
candidate the running for this prophecy
one who only just made the cut Jon Snow
if our last game of Thrones theory is
correct jon is the son of Lyanna stark
and rhaegar targaryen making him the
only other living Targaryen in the world
other than Danny and that means Dragon's
Blood big check number one but just
having the blood of the dragon doesn't
necessarily fulfill the other parts of
the prophecy luckily for John Doe we see
in season 5 episode hardhome that he
possesses a sword able to take down the
White Walkers so that's another point
for him the big question here though is
was he born amid salt and smoke
yeah kinda but only if you squint at it
real hard his actual birth took place at
the end of one of the biggest wars in
Westeros so
Boulton smoke there I guess or it could
refer to another birth of his his birth
into the Nights Watch well Danny was
across the Narrow Sea producing dragons
from the biggest s'mores roast ever Jon
Snow is having a crisis of conscience at
the wall at the outbreak of the war of
five Kings when his old home had just
been burned to the ground
he left the Nights Watch and was only
rounded back up by Sam his loveable
comic relief well not a literal birth
this was the actual moment when Jon Snow
left his old life behind and committed
to the Nights Watch we've never seen him
waver in this commitment since that
point in the show except for that whole
Ygritte thing but it is reasonable to
accept this moment as John's birth into
the night watch which also coincides
with the timing of the same comment over
Danny and another point in his favor
here is that he's a guy and the prophecy
promised a prince so there you go
between their personalities histories
and abilities John and Danny are bolts
pretty ideal candidates so shouldn't
this episode be over now why is there
still a whole nother page of text that I
have to read the only problem with one
of these to fulfilling the prophecy is
the author who wrote the prophecy our
buddy George isn't your typical fiction
series writer he stated in the past that
while he loves classic fantasy writers
like j.r.r tolkien he believes that the
traditional fantasy tropes a lot of them
created have hurt fantasy fiction more
than they've helped that's a direct
quote as a result he intentionally goes
out of his way to avoid them with a Song
of Ice and Fire
and even if he hadn't stated that
explicitly you can see it in the books
main characters die all the time good
bad somewhere in the middle he just up
and die some go unceremoniously without
long goodbyes without redemption without
fulfilling a heroic destiny it's that
unpredictability that makes this series
so great and what makes me believe that
neither Danny nor Jon Snow are actually
the heroes from the prophecy girl Martin
himself has said that quote prophecies
are a double-edged sword you have to
handle them carefully they can add depth
and interest to a book but you don't
want to be too literal or too easy
end quotes and that's the problem with
John and Danny it's too easy
instead knowing that george RR martin is
the type of author who enjoys sadistic
plot twists our prints that was promised
as someone who also meets all the
requirements of the prophecy but will
have a much harder time having to live
with its consequences and that someone
is Sir Jorah Mormont's that's right
I submit to you that this banished scaly
skin to friendzone deserter is gonna
save the world from snow zombies Wow
when I put it that way it really looks
like he has a long road ahead of him but
Jorah Mormont fits the bill let's think
this through let's start with his birth
conditions we've established that for
all our candidates birth can be defined
as a moment when you're born into a new
life Danny's funeral pyre moment also
applies to Sir Jorah no he didn't
survive an inferno or give birth to
dragons but he did make an important
vamos in season five Jorah tells Tyrion
it was that moment he decided to commit
his life to Dany abandoning the whole
prospect of ever going back to Westeros
a new life a rebirth in the smoke of a
funeral pyre and just like Jon Snow he
committed to a new destiny that we've
never seen him leave even when Danny is
kicking him out every other episode and
he also did it under the same red
messenger as the other two the comet
streaking across the sky and with
Dragons coming shortly thereafter so you
might be asking yourself what about the
salt well again in season five when he
and Tyrion are attacked while sailing
through the ruins of old valaria Jorah
contracts greyscale an often fatal
disease that leaves the skin stiff and
dead a new chapter of his life begins in
this moment that just so happens to take
place on salty seawater I can see it I
almost have you convinced but I know
that there's still one big missing piece
he
the blood of the dragon and save your
comments you're right Jorah is no
Targaryen but notice that the prophecy
doesn't state that the hero is the blood
of the dragon it states that he has the
blood of the Dragon and that could mean
a lot of things we assume it's having
the blood pumping through your veins but
it could just be referencing his sword
possessing the blood of the Dragon say
by killing a dragon we have seen these
dragons lash out at Dany in the past and
Jorah would do anything to protect her
and before you think I'm reading too
much into this
consider the following in his second
attempt to temper his blade Zhora high
captured a lion and pierced its chest
what did Jorah just do earlier the
season capture a lion Tyrion of House
Lannister and what two days or have to
do in the end to produce the blade that
would end the night pierced the heart of
his beloved wife who else in the series
love someone as deeply and sincerely as
Jorah loves Daenerys certainly not
Ramsay and Sansa I'll tell you that ooh
too soon but joking aside if george RR
martin truly wants to throw fantasy
tropes out the window and shock us even
more than the red and purple weddings
Jorah being the prince of prophecy
forced to kill Danny in order to
retrieve the blood of the dragon just so
he can stop the White Walkers that would
certainly do it but hey that's just a
theory of film theory
and cut
welcome back to the super amazing end
card tournaments so who do you think is
the prince that was promised it's gotta
be one of the three Danny John or Jorah
so click on the one you think it's gonna
end up being and check back next time to
see who won but before you vote remember
the night is dark and full of terrors
so subscribe oh I'm sorry did I forget
to mention that part of the prophecy
yeah here let me read it to you
quote ye who subscribed shall pass
through the night with the guidance of a
great theorist and quote huh yeah
so don't let roll or down gone maybe
light that fire subscribe now if you'll
excuse me I need to watch that white
Walker battle seat again it was
incredible
maybe one of the strongest episodes of
the series so far Tyrion and Danny
finally getting a chance to talk ah
awesome fanboy out